The joe rogan experience,
the,
the history of the human race is so weird in terms of the rise and fall of these
civilizations and cultures that were always,
uh,
at least I am always looking at like what,
how long is this going to last?
Like how long has this one particular nation going to keep it together?
And if you look at how many different countries have been around that,
just how many,
you know,
w a dominant culture is Rome for instance.
Like the just now it's just Italy.
It's just normal,
you know,
it's like a normal European country.
It used to be this conquering nation.
Like how,
how long can we kind of keep this thing up and what are your thoughts on the
future of,
of just even the idea of nations.
It seems like our bout our boundaries and our borders,
the way we have a online,
this ability to communicate with people all over the place,
everywhere.
It seems to me to lessen the necessary or the need rather for for borders and
for,
for these walls that we're now literally and figuratively talking about putting
up,
you guys going to be a,
a kind of a balance.
It's,
I mean,
an interesting thing about nation states now is that there,
there's this a sense of which they're treated as immortal.
Ah Ha.
That whereas as you mentioned for most of history,
they were conquering emperors and a nation.
Nations were wiped off the map and engulfed and conquered.
And you know,
now you look at a map of the world and uh,
it's actually not that different from what it was 70 years ago.
I mean their colonies that achieved independence.
There's some big states like Soviet Union that brought fragmented,
but the borders in between the wrist,
Soviet republics are now borders between nation states and no nation has gone
out of existence through conquest since this is 1945,
uh,
at least record internationally recognized state by the,
by the UN.
So there's this norm,
even though the borders are often,
you know,
crazy then they were arbitrary lines drawn a map.
But one of the reasons that,
um,
again,
this is counter intuitive that wars have gone down and deaths and wars have gone
down,
is that borders are now treated as sacrosanct by the kind of international
community.
Not 100% of the time you had Russia,
uh,
annexing Crimea.
But those are exceptions.
But by and large,
unlike say in the past in the 19th century where the u s had a,
an unpaid debt from Mexico.
So it conquered,
you know,
Texas and Colorado and kick in Nevada and California.
That doesn't happen anymore.
And so the borders are kind of been grandfathered in.
And that's one of the reasons why the,
uh,
the,
the world has been more stable in terms of the,
uh,
the,
the map.
On the other hand,
as you mentioned,
there's another sense in which we have this global community.
The trick transcends borders.
We have things like the European Union,
we have the United Nations,
we have a trade agreements like Nafta,
which tried to get simultaneously the grandfathered borders,
but this extra layer of cooperation that transcends the borders.
And we need the more and more despite the fact that our current president is
pushing back against the global community.
Uh,
but because there are problems that are global that my migration,
terrorism,
climate pollution,
rogue states,
and the fact that people,
even if they,
even if you grew up in France and you consider yourself a French citizen,
you want to be able to spend a summer in,
um,
you know,
in,
in Italy or in England or in Belgium,
if,
if that's where there's a good job and there's a desire among people to be able
to move to wherever the opportunities are best.
So there's going to be some kind of compromise I think between keeping the,
the,
the nation state borders just so you don't have constant wars of conquest and
border disputes,
but allowing the world and allowing the people of the world to take advantage of
a true global community.
Yeah.
I feel like that's one of the things that people were most upset about Brexit
was that this is a,
the,
even though they,
the people that were pro Brexit felt like this was in the interest of the UK and
the interest of England to be separate from all this because they were doing
better and because they didn't want all the negative possibilities from all
these other places coming into their environment.
But the,
what I think that people,
what they didn't like about it was the idea that this is a,
uh,
a regressive move and that the progressive move is that we would all move
towards,
uh,
this idea of a global community of this entire world being free and connected.
And you know,
we've talked about,
um,
some of the problems that Paris has with a immigration.
We showed some of the videos of these,
uh,
these immigrants that had just littered all over the street and taking this
place apart and we're looking at it going,
man,
that is a,
that is a real tragedy.
But what it represents is a bunch of people that really don't have anything.
Like the real tragedy is that these people live like this.
And the real tragedy is not that they've done it to Paris,
the real tragedies that these people exist at all and that they moved to Paris
looking for a better life and now they're stuck in this situation where you
know,
there's not a lot of sanitation and the garbage is all over the place.
They're littering everywhere.
And it's,
I wonder if we ever will have a world where there isn't a place where you can go
and ship a factory and pay people a dollar an hour because they don't need a
dollar an hour because it's just like living in Los Angeles or just like living
in Phoenix.
Like you'd never be able to pay someone a dollar an hour because there's too
much opportunity.
The world has caught up and surpassed it.
Yeah,
I mean there's a number of,
of a really complicated issues that they,
you know,
mobility is in general a good thing and countries do well when they welcome any
immigrants,
but,
you know,
not,
not on the short term.
Yeah.
Not too many,
too fast.
Faster than they can be assimilated and integrated into the new country.
So it,
just opening the doors right.
Probably is not a good idea.
No country really does that,
but building the wall is a terrible idea to,
uh,
and of course the,
the,
the best way to prevent,
uh,
you know,
massive amounts of,
of migration is to make life better in the countries of origin that is happening
slowly and unevenly.
But it's been noted that even United States in Mexico,
more people,
uh,
are going,
or the same number of people are doing the reverse migration from the u s back
to Mexico now that the economy of Mexico is so much my own parents,
25 years.
Okay.
Yeah.
My parents live in Mexico.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah.
Um,
and there is,
uh,
a,
um,
a hard to detect,
but there is a huge improvement in the standard of living in what used to be
called the third world,
the developing world where,
um,
the,
if you look at the cutoff for extreme poverty,
it's kind of defined,
defined somewhat arbitrarily is a dollar 90 per person per day,
kind of the bare,
bare,
bare minimum to feed,
feed your family.
Uh,
it's down now from a 50% a few decades ago to 10% now and the United Nations to
set the goal of bringing it to zero by the year 2030.
And what street?
What is causing that?
What's causing the change?
So a lot of it is,
um,
globalization that I'm,
even though that's kind of a villain in many people's eyes,
but when you have,
uh,
a huge global market than a,
and the introduction of,
of,
uh,
factories and industrialization in China,
in India and Bangladesh,
sometimes the conditions are grim.
But the conditions being a peasant in the rice patties was even grimmer.
And when,
when you have,
uh,
people integrated to the economy,
selling their products on a world stage,
uh,
they can get richer.
And so a lot also better policies.
We have governments that,
um,
are no longer a communist or like really heavy handed forms of socialism where
everything is defined by the bureaucrats and you need 50 licenses to do anything
and you have a little bit more economic flexibility,
uh,
that tends to make a country's richer.
It doesn't mean that you could do away with regulations on workplace safety and
a environment and as countries get richer,
they tend to be more protective of their workers and of the environment.
Right.
Uh,
and leaders that,
uh,
kind of think of their mandate as how do I get my country to be richer?
And the most dramatic case was China where,
uh,
you know,
Mao had these harebrained schemes of huge collective farms and people smelting
iron in their backyards and you know,
anything that occurred to him in the middle of the night,
he would force on hundreds of millions of people and it costs these massive
famines.
Then Deng,
Deng Xiaoping took over and he said,
getting rich as good.
Uh,
and he said,
black cat,
white cat,
as long as it catches mice,
it's a good cat.
So much more pragmatic,
much more concerned with the welfare of their citizens.
When you have leaders who have that mindset,
then the,
their country can,
can get,
get wealthier and their citizens better off
now.
But are you concerned,
I mean,
I,
I agree with you that it is probably is one of the reasons why these people are
experiencing this greater quality of life is because of globalization,
because of these factors are moving in,
but they're living lives that are very different and maybe perhaps it's by our
standards that their lives are better.
That may be if there,
if these indigenous people were living this sort of specific subsistence
lifestyle,
that even though on paper they would be existing in extreme poverty,
but if they're perhaps like living in the jungle or somewhere along those lines
where you have access to all these natural resources that even though they'd be
living in extreme poverty,
they'd be living maybe,
perhaps even a better life by just eating the fish and eating the plants and
hunting and fishing and doing what they had normally done for thousands and
thousands of years rather than making a dollar an hour and a Nike factory.
Right?
I mean,
it's certainly true that I've,
uh,
indigenous peoples who are living in,
um,
hunter and horticultural lifestyles that there are no real crimes in displacing
them.
Often,
not so much by factories,
but by a miners and loggers.
But the,
the,
they're a very tiny fraction of the world's population.
You know,
tragically,
uh,
the vast majority of poor people or more are peasants,
not,
uh,
not Ho horticulturalists and right.
And you know,
they're kind of agricultural laborers and for them just based on their own
choices,
uh,
often the factory life is a,
is an improvement.
It's an improvement,
not just because they're not,
uh,
kind of in the fields,
knee deep in muck,
pulling up seedlings and getting bitten by disease,
carrying a bugs.
But,
um,
for women,
uh,
being able to move from a a village to a city often means liberation that they
can start a business and their kids to school,
uh,
be out from under the thumbs of their husbands and the husband's family because
there's a kind of a can be a liberation just just as what our aunts,
our ancestors did when they left the farms for,
for cities,
uh,
150 years ago.
So there's not to say there is an exploitation and a and cruelty,
which ought to be opposed.
And in the case of native peoples,
often criminal,
uh,
displacements,
but on the whole globalization has led to this escape from grinding poverty for
literally hundreds of millions of people.
So,
even when they move the factories into these places in charge or our pay them a
dollar an hour rather,
it's still a dollar more an hour than they would have gotten if the factory had
been there
in,
in many cases.
That's true.
We just want to say there isn't exploitation.
But you know,
we look at our,
our answer,
you know,
my grandparents worked in a clothing factory and uh,
when,
when the,
when they emigrated from Poland to Canada and,
uh,
it often is a route to upward mobility.
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard for us to accept that.
I don't even think about it that way because it was saying,
well,
why,
how come they don't have to pay these Mexican folks minimum wage just like they
do in America?
Like,
well,
why don't they have the same sort of setup we do here?
It just seems cruel.
It doesn't impair,
no doubt there is cruelty.
But the,
the,
the relevant comparison is not so much,
uh,
the difference between working in a factory there and working in an office and,
you know,
in Berkeley or,
or Manhattan.
It's the difference between working in a factory there and,
uh,
and,
and laboring in the fields there.
And the people were often given that choice.
They line up to the factory jobs.
Do you anticipate a time where there is no third world and there is no like a
massive economic disparity?
It's,
it's conceivable.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a ways off,
but it's happened and huge parts of the world and mean.
We forget that places like South Korea now,
you know,
this rich,
uh,
upper middle class society,
not so long ago.
That was the third world.
I mean,
they were,
they were hungry.
They were,
uh,
the children died young.
Um,
lot of them living in squalor.
Uh,
and that was true in certainly in China.
Lots of parts,
places,
parts of China now that are,
are pretty much middle class that were a squalid not so long ago.
Uh,
Singapore.
I have,
uh,
an anecdote in the book and enlightenment now of my,
um,
uh,
ex mother in law who grew up in Singapore and she remembers a childhood meal in
which her family split one egg for ways.
I was back in the,
uh,
in the 1940s.
And Singapore is now one of the world's richest countries.
So it can't happen.
It is happening.
The most remote,
poorest parts of the world are going to be the hardest to bring up to middle
class standards.
Like,
you know,
Congo,
like Haiti,
like Afghanistan,
but large parts of the world,
there has been a huge increase in the standard of living.
Okay.